there's a school in las vegas taking a
new approach to learning called the
girls athletic leadership school or the
acronym gals
focused on movement based leadership
what's that heather well eight news now
a proud community partner and as you're
going to see this school goes so much
beyond academics this all-girls school
helping young women reach their
potential in spite of some of the
obstacles that they face
no boys
no distractions
kobe is a seventh grader at gals the
girls athletic leadership school in las
vegas it's her first year and she's
already settled in science you know it's
a lot it's a lot of fun you can do a lot
of experiments you can learn a lot
and it's also a little bit of a mix of
like history in there so i think that's
really cool girls today need to be
empowered
science teacher terry proud says gals is
a game changer i wish they had something
like this when i was going to school we
have a milk and an apple breaking the
mold and creating a safe space where
young women can thrive and excel both
academically and personally our goal
is to train
our young adults to be leaders they do
that with small classes that focus on
everything a traditional school offers
and other programs to allow these young
women to grow through movement and
leadership we do have a class here
called gal series which
is that time for students to you know
listen to different stories and they
love it everybody's like smiling and are
happy so it just puts you in a good room
students once shy now compelled to
interact i always be greeting people
when they first come in we have students
that are really quiet and and maybe not
real confident in themselves and it's
amazing to watch that change and it
doesn't take very long and just like her
name sunshine she's beaming with
excitement for her future and i'm about
to follow my dreams no matter and if
anything goes downhill no matter what
obstacles come my way i'm gonna still
achieve that it will make a difference
in their lives and their education and
allow them to be productive citizens in
society and achieve academic success
that is an awesome story heather will
keep an eye on the gals school meantime